[Music]
once upon a time a man named walt wanted
to build a city nay a kingdom
in florida swampland as you can see on
this map we have a perfect location in
florida almost in the very center of the
state
in fact we selected this site because
it's so easy for tourists and florida
residents to get here by automobile the
company secretly purchased 27 400 acres
in small parcels that together formed a
land mass roughly the size of manhattan
as you can see on this master plan the
theme park and all the other tourist
facilities filled just one small area of
our enormous florida project he wanted
plenty of space to keep the type of
tacky tourist shops that encircled
disneyland plopped in the middle of
anaheim california from encroaching on
his new kingdom there's enough land here
to hold all the ideas and plans we could
possibly imagine disney filmed this
presentation in a bid to convince
lawmakers that his extraordinary dream
required extraordinary powers
he wanted total control over the land so
that politics couldn't interfere the
heart of everything we'll be doing in
disney world
will be our experimental prototype city
of gamora
we call it epcot
epcot's dynamic urban center
will offer the excitement and variety of
activities found only in metropolitan
cities i call it a vatican with mouse
ears because it's like the autonomous
government that the vatican has
though he passed away in 1966 before the
plan came to fruition walt disney got
his wish the year following his death
local lawmakers approved the creation of
the reedy creek improvement district a
remarkable experiment in private
governance that has thrived for the past
55 years
enter governor ron desantis disney
should not run its own government
[Applause]
in march disney ceo bob chapeck issued
an internal memo stating that the
company opposed a law that was recently
passed in florida banning instruction on
sexual orientation and gender identity
in k-3 public school classrooms
desantis whose office didn't respond to
our interview request reacted by
dissolving the reedy creek improvement
district as of june 1 2023 which would
bring this half-century experiment in
semi-privatized governance
to an end
walt disney's project was inspired by
the futuristic vision of the 1964
world's fair overseen by his personal
friend the new york power broker robert
moses the company had showcased future
epcot attractions such as the people
mover and carousel of progress it later
hired the fair's executive vice
president to oversee the construction of
disney world
disneyland california became a social
center a center of national and
international tourism according to
austrian-born l.a based urban designer
victor groon who was also the visionary
behind the indoor shopping mall he
called it a prime example of cellular
urbanism where a dense pedestrian
friendly central business district is
the heart of the city with arteries
running into it from the outer
residential and recreational areas
walt disney who reportedly kept a copy
of groone's book the heart of our cities
on hand wanted his experimental
prototype community of tomorrow to be a
showcase of the first true cellular city
the broad green belt and recreation
lands
and finally
the low density neighborhood residential
streets
disney world had a profound influence on
urban planning for one thing it inspired
planned communities and attractions
throughout florida which has more than
1200 special governance districts
while epcot never became the functional
city of 20 000 residents that was
promised in disney's film presentation
the company did build and maintain a
vast transportation infrastructure
including a monorail system that carries
about 150 000 guests a day connecting
with a network of buses shuttles trams
cable cars and boats to move guests
between its four theme parks two water
parks shopping and recreation centers
sports complex campground and more than
29 resort hotels
disney world's governance model was also
influential as a strategy for dealing
with the red tape endemic to local
planning boards robert moses exemplified
one model of circumventing local
politics he never held elected office
yet remade the landscape of new york
through his control of the state's
powerful public agencies empowered to
borrow money and seize land through
eminent domain but the flip side was
that moses had little accountability so
he bulldozed neighborhoods and nearly
flattened manhattan soho with an
expressway the need is not just
procuring the old ills of old cities
we think the need is for starting from
scratch on virgin land and building a
special kind of new community while
moses ran rough shot over established
communities
disney opted to build a new economy in
central florida on virgin land with his
strategic real estate purchases and
special district exempting him from the
politics of zoning and land use
regulation the result was a more
effective model of governing land use
because the reedy creek board is
appointed and funded by a company with
an incentive to create a highly
functional design the project met the
needs of its customers while keeping
costs in line epcot will always be a
showcase to the world
for the ingenuity and imagination of
american free enterprise
disney has benefited from the reedy
creek improvement district because it
gets to control everything and the
awesome authority that the disney
company has put those two things
together creativity and control
historian and political scientist
richard fogelsong is the author of
married to the mouse walt disney world
and orlando a definitive history of the
disney corporation's relationship with
florida's government
he says that the company's special
jurisdiction insulated it from
interference from county planning
departments that's what made disney
world's distinctive architecture
possible
they were building cinderella's castle
278
feet high made of fiberglass and you
wouldn't find a provision for that
fiberglass tall building in a building
code but that didn't mean skimping on
safety
disney hired a nationally recognized
building code expert as well as the
former army corps of engineers general
who'd been the former governor of the
panama canal zone to oversee disney
world's construction they
wanted to make sure that the tourists
who come here are safe otherwise they
might sue so there was a financial
incentive for the disney company to
conduct its inspections responsibly and
they weren't sure they would get that
from
a municipal government legally reedy
creek started as a special drainage
district so that the company would have
the municipal authority to empty the
swamp that it planned to build over
but it morphed into a full-fledged
government with its own fire department
hospital water and power systems and
even the right though never exercised to
form its own police department
it even had the authority to build a
nuclear power plant within the district
which he never pursued perhaps because
that would have invited onerous federal
regulation what's remarkable is how fast
disney's dream came together the company
transformed 2500 acres of undeveloped
swamp land into the disney world complex
in just four years
the magic kingdom opened to the public
on october 1st
1971.
disney world inspired future experiments
in private governance including a
variety of attempts to build charter
cities run by private corporations in
central america and african countries
with the goal of spurring economic
growth by preserving personal liberty
but walt disney was adamant that no
permanent citizens reside in reedy creek
they were afraid of democracy because
they well understood that if people
actually lived in the reedy creek
improvement district that they would be
able to vote there and wall didn't want
that
they wanted planning and zoning
authority but not at the cost of having
real residents who could vote there
disney did create two adjacent
residential cities bay lake and lake
buena vista with a combined population
of about 53 permanent residents who get
to elect the local government officials
voters must own an acre of land in the
district to participate in the reedy
creek elections now you might wonder who
are the people who live in those
residences answer they are trusted
long-term
disney employees so those are like
company towns and those are employees
beholden to the company it makes it
possible to do things that would not be
possible in a real world community
disney was so protective of reedy
creek's autonomy that when former ceo
michael eisner created the residential
city of celebration on the property in
1996 he actually de-annexed it from the
reedy creek improvement district prior
to residents moving into their homes so
as not to risk the intrusion of politics
in 2013 honduras a country hobbled by
bureaucracy corruption and weak property
rights passed a national law authorizing
private cities which paved the way for
several attempts to build autonomous
zones protected from local politics but
after the election of the democratic
socialist ziamara castro earlier this
year the government repealed that law
undermining the charter city movement
and this underscores one of the hazards
of building private cities their
autonomy is vulnerable to the whims of
populist politicians from the left and
the right they don't want to see their
kids go to kindergarten and have this
stuff jammed down their throats and so i
just stand with the people i stand
against a lot of media and a lot of big
corporations desantis signed the
parental rights and education bill into
law in march 2022 amidst a national
media firestorm critics call it the
don't say gay bill florida's so-called
don't say gay bill legislation that is
designed to target and attack the kids
who need the support support the most
disney has vowed to help have florida's
don't say gay bill repealed
the law prohibits any classroom
instruction on sexual orientation and
gender identity in grades k-3 and
instructs that the subjects only be
taught in older grades in an
age-appropriate manner as determined by
the state department of education
disney a famously lgbt-friendly company
responded to employee complaints about
corporate silence with a letter from ceo
bob chapek issuing an apology for his
silence calling the bill a challenge to
human rights promising to donate
corporate funds to combat similar
legislation in other states and pause
all political donations in the state of
florida
desantis and his allies in the state
legislature then targeted reedy creek
reedy creek gives them a competitive
advantage that their competitors do not
have
state representative randy fine
introduced the bill in the florida house
that would end the reedy creek
improvement district disney announced
they were going to use the special
privileges that the state had given them
to make it a priority to repeal a bill
that we never passed a supposed don't
say gabe bill we thought that was a
little bit out of line and that created
this groundswell of support to start to
take a look at things like this reedy
creek does grant disney some advantages
beyond streamlining zoning and building
codes the district can issue tax-exempt
bonds to finance infrastructure
improvements on the property and disney
doesn't incur the same improvement fees
when it develops its land that other
companies operating under traditional
governance do but the company covers the
cost of its own municipal services by
paying more than 100 million dollars a
year in taxes to reedy creek on top of
the property taxes it pays to the
counties and it reimburses the local
sheriff's department for its presence on
the property
focal song says walt disney wasn't after
tax breaks the reedy creek improvement
district is a special taxing district
and through it the disney company
believe it or not taxes itself
to be able to produce particular public
services and build particular
infrastructure that are specific to its
own needs it didn't want to have to rely
on orange county like it relied upon
anaheim california it wanted just the
things that it needed for its purposes
and was therefore willing to tax itself
to get them
the company clearly wants to retain
those powers i think not so much to have
power
not because it's money saving for them
but rather because it produces
efficiency for them what has been going
on here is i believe companies have been
able to be bullied woke leftists have
just simply bullied them screamed and
yelled and thrown temper tantrums and so
companies go what's the path of least
resistance fine fine fine we'll throw
you a bone well they're now learning in
florida there's a cost to doing that in
the united states shouldn't a private
citizen even if he's a ceo of a big
company feel free to criticize
government policy without facing
retaliation
well i reject the premise that it was
retaliation um for starters when you
treat every company the same
that cannot be retaliation if we were
treating disney worse than its
competitors you would argue um that it
would be retaliation but when you kick
the hornet's nest sometimes issues pop
up if it's an unfair treatment for
disney why not look toward to expanding
and creating more of these special zones
do you think that is
something worth considering or was this
ultimately a mistake
well i mean i think you can create take
some of the things that are good and
grant those without creating a a special
zone disney has created 1.1 billion
dollars of taxpayer debt i don't know
that there's a matter of good public
policy that private corporations should
be able to issue government debt that's
about as far away from a free market as
it gets
but unlike normal municipal bond debt
that's repaid through taxation
reedy creek's bonds have been backed by
the revenue of the disney company though
that could change if the district is
dissolved
the orange county tax collector
estimates the dissolution could lead to
a 15 to 20 percent property tax increase
in the county to compensate bondholders
for reedy creek's more than one billion
dollars in debt and to cover the
millions of dollars of annual expenses
in maintaining the property's
infrastructure i don't see how the
governor and republicans in the state
legislature are going to be able to
finalize this step to dissolve the reedy
creek improvement district and not leave
taxpayers and voters having to
compensate the disney company fine says
that orange and osceola counties could
set up their own special taxing
districts to target disney and make up
for the shortfall and desantis has
suggested absorbing reedy creek into the
state government to continue extracting
disney's money focal song expects that
disney and the state of florida will
reach a compromise to save reedy creek
before the june 2023 deadline i think
there are too many benefits and you
might say too many children for this
divorce to occur
the reading creek improvement district
in my opinion is something like a
free nuptial agreement that protected
disney's powers into the future
walt disney died and they ended up
building amazing theme parks in an
amazing tourism destination but they
never built a city so one could argue
that the marriage was created on false
pretenses you said that this is not
retaliatory
but
it is clearly sending a message um
there's a message is that
kind of the relationship between
corporate america and government that we
want to see going forward
we're not interested in getting in the
way of free speech but when a visitor to
our state says we're going to use
special privileges that we've been given
to to to retaliate and get rid of a law
that we never passed that's a slap in
the face to the people of florida and
we're not going to put up with it
i mean to call disney visitor to the
state they've been here for over five
over half a century are they really
they're kind of a staple of florida
aren't they
um but that and but that's what we
learned that disney was acting like a
businessman they said we demand that you
accept our california values in the
state of florida a florida company
wouldn't have done this
if reedy creek is dissolved what's the
legacy of walt disney's dream city built
from scratch on a florida swamp
i think there are going to be unintended
consequences and i think they're going
to be great um i think if i was
considering building a theme park in the
state of florida i would go gosh do i
want to compete with a company that gets
special perks and privileges that i
don't get it's true that no other
company was ever able to secure the kind
of autonomy that disney did in florida
even though it may annoy politicians
resentful of giving up their control
over a large swath of land
disney has created a model of land use
studied worldwide by businesses and
governments
the reedy creek improvement district in
its half century of life so far has
offered a glimpse of what's possible
when land development is governed by a
private company with a long-term stake
rather than the political whims and
interests of elected officials
disney world is in many ways a city
dedicated to
free enterprise without residence true
without democracy
but with a reliance on a private
corporation to efficiently provide
public services
so it is kind of amazing that
self-described conservatives now
would want to take away from a
well-known and pretty beloved
company
the ability to privatize public services
and to deregulate and rely more on the
private marketplace i'm confident we can
create right here in disney world a
showcase to the world of the american
free enterprise system
i believe we can build a community that
more people will talk about and come to
look at
than any other area in the world we're
ready to go right now